all right let's get the big boy this is  a new one yep here it comes  oh boy oh boy holy I mean come on what  come on it's just too it's too good it's  too massive I can't even handle it oh my  God  this is my hand and this is Korea  [Music]  look at the Soviet energy match Soviet  energy map I don't read this but I think  this is like  I don't know I'm actually not even gonna  find on what it is no one has something  to do with the energy needs of the US I  think it's energy production maybe maybe  it's like  I don't know  some resources somebody tell me what  this is freaking gorgeous I've been  obsessed with maps my whole life and  never thought I'd have a day where I  could just put up a map in my studio and  just look at it and just to have it as  big as me